one of my favorite sets of memories from
living here in this apartment in
Milwaukee where we moved back to in 2015
is of the times when my wife was away on
trips either to New York or to
California for work or to take care of
her mother in the hospital and it was me
and our four-legged family on our own
here and the way that we slept that
that's the thing that actually came to
mind so for those who don't know we
originally had or I should say my wife
originally had and I sort of inherited
as uh you know somebody getting married
to her four different animals two
sisters who were kittens who survived an
apartment fire in New York City and that
was Teensy and Sassy TNC unfortunate
really died in 2014 she was about 12
years old and she had liver failure but
we also had two dogs Magnus and Amica
and Magnus and Amica were both younger
than the cats and Mika was about I think
about a year a year and a half younger
than Magnus and they were both black lab
mixes but very different one was a flat
coat retriever black lab mix and that
was Magnus and he was very wiry and fast
and then there was Amika who was like a
tank she topped out at around 110 pounds
at her Peak when she was in you know
super great shape and doing agility and
she was a mix between black lab and
Catahoula leopard hound and perhaps some
pit bull in there as well and so we
moved here to Milwaukee and the dogs you
know adapted very quickly we've got a
great park that's just about you know
essentially a block uh only a block from
us so we'd take them out there to do
their business three times a day or so
and I also took them on some pretty long
walks throughout the downtown of
Milwaukee the Third Ward uh over by
Marquette up the river walk and so all
over the place even sometimes down by
the lake I'd pile them both into the car
and drive them down to the lakefront and
we'd walk along the lake sometimes in
the day sometimes at night and then of
course there was sassy
sassy was the cat who essentially ran
the show she was you know she sometimes
she'd be about 10 pounds or so I think
she may have topped out around 12 and
then every once in a while she'd like
lose a lot of weight and get down to
eight or seven pounds and then we'd feed
her as much as we could and she was you
know as I mentioned a little bit older
than the dogs they had both been puppies
and she and Teensy had kind of let them
know who is in charge so you know my
wife was working for The Culinary
Institute of America as a contractor at
that time and so she had to go to the
Hyde Park Campus sometimes for various
events you know that would last quite a
few days or she had to go out to the
California Campus and be out there
sometimes for quite a long time as well
it could be conferences it could be
meetings it could be all sorts of things
and she was helping to astound publish
and build the at this point quite
successful food Business School
so there was that going on and then
there was a Health crisis with her mom
that took place as well
which was pretty scary and so my wife
was fortunately her you know her parents
lived nearby and so she could be there
like all the time and then I was here
taking care of the animals and doing my
work
and so when we first moved in we got
everything you know in here in boxes and
we were upstairs and we didn't actually
have a bed at that time the bed came
while she was gone and I had to put it
together and then you know undo the
mattress and all that sort of stuff and
so we were
um sleeping on these Japanese mats that
were about this thick that we we had two
big black ones that we would roll out
and
um then you know lay some some sheets
over and some blankets and the dogs
always like to sleep with us as did the
cats as a matter of fact when I was
talking with Andy about this she said in
one of the places where she lived she
would actually say Okay bedtime and they
would all pile into the bed with her so
some people don't like you know animals
on the bed we're we're the opposite I
actually grew up in a household where my
dog lady slept with me basically every
every night and if I was at a friend's
house she would still sleep in my bed so
anyway my wife is away and you know
there's a lot of unpacking to do and
stuff like that and then you know at
night uh you know we would all go up and
lay down together Magnus like to be
pretty close he was a very cuddly pup
and you could wiggle him around and
stuff sassy very much liked and she
would actually as I said run the show
she would sometimes shoe the dogs away
by being very persistent she liked to be
in my arms a lot but she also liked to
cuddle up with the dogs Amika would
sometimes cuddle want to cuddle up but
then she'd get too hot and you know
start stuffling she also liked to be
under the blankets from time to time and
so it was it was quite nice we'd wake up
every morning and you know the first
thing we would do is is uh go downstairs
get at the leashes and head out to the
park so they could have their you know
morning business and then come in and
they'd you know have some some breakfast
and I'd make myself some breakfast sassy
would eventually come down the stairs on
her own and be wandering around doing
whatever she wanted to do and uh yeah it
was kind of kind of cool together that
laying all this one pack and then I you
know I I remember doing that a couple
times when Andy was away just with the
bed but that wasn't something really
that new because quite often we got like
a king-sized bed
um we'd have both dogs and and you know
sassy as well in the bed with us which
didn't always make for great sleep but
in in the winter was quite nice because
we often wouldn't put on the heat until
it got pretty cold in here as a matter
of fact we had kind of a a running
contest to see how long we could go each
year without turning the heat on now you
might say that's a foolish thing to do
what about pipes and all that we live in
an apartment complex right and we're in
a building with two floors of tenants
beneath us we live on the 8th and ninth
floor of a loft apartment so there
wasn't any danger of anything going
wrong with that it's just you know you
got to bundle up while you're in here
and animals you know great source of
heat and humans turn out to be a great
source of heat for them too so the other
time that I really remember was when
Andy's mom was uh in in rough shape and
so Andy was staying with her at the
hospital and then oftentimes later at uh
their their house out in Brookfield as
her mom recovered
and so I think it was a period of about
two weeks or so that it was just me and
the dogs and sassy and I was I think
finishing up the semester at Marquette
University because I do remember having
some classes
and you know we would do all of our
normal stuff take our walks you know
enjoy ourselves have our meals and then
I remember we had these big Yogi bow
cushions that
um
were originally for humans they're kind
of a cool thing that we bought while we
were still in New York we saw him
demonstrated at a mall in Albany and
they came in a bunch of different things
and it was sort of like modular
furniture that was actually bean bags
filled with really really tiny pellets
and very comfortable you know so you can
imagine what took place pretty quickly
they weren't just for the humans you
know I think that actually
um Amica might have been a little bit
scared of the yogibo at first and then
she found that she really liked laying
on it Magnus liked it too sassy loved it
she would curl up with them sometimes
she would just be on a yogi Ball by
herself my wife actually bought this is
a bit of a side note other Yogi bow
things later on which then sassy
immediately claimed she'd gotten the
technology down in her head so to speak
and so that two-week period
um you know I'd make myself some dinner
and then I would put on a show and lay
down on the yogi bow and of course it
was you know
um I want to say like late November
early December so it was getting pretty
cold in the apartment still hadn't
turned the heat on and you know we
developed this kind of nighttime routine
which was similar to what we had when
when Andy my wife was gone upstairs on
those those mats which is everybody knew
it was time to hunker down and get ready
for bed and so typically what would end
up happening is I'd get out the blankets
and
um you know lay down with part of my
body on one of these Yogi bows and
it was most often Magnus although
sometimes Amica would want to cuddle up
close and oftentimes sassy would worm
her way in there between us sometimes
sassy would actually go over on the
other Yogi bow where you know usually
Amica was laying down and then curl up
with with her and so we'd all be there
huddled together again like one big pack
me the biggest one of them all and then
Amica and then Magnus and then little
sassy and you know people would get up
and move around at night a little bit
you know shift position
um sassy might go and use the litter box
the dogs are sassy might get up and
drink some water eat a little kibble
different things like that sometimes
sassy would uh sassy and Magnus both
would sometimes you know prowl a little
bit at night you know so she might go we
might hear going up the stairs and then
coming back down Magnus had kind of a
guard dog mentality so he might go to
the the apartment door sniff a little
bit and then come back by us uh and that
was that was what we did and it was just
kind of a a fun comfortable
cozy thing that made the time with Andy
gone
um pass much nicer than if we'd all had
like our own little sleeping spots
um you know it was a way of uh just
hanging out and enjoying each other's
company and then you know we'd wake up
in the morning and now we were already
downstairs so I would just uh throw on a
bit more clothes you know my boots and
stuff like that that take the dogs out
come in we'd all have our breakfast I'd
sit around drinking some coffee and
getting ready to get on with the day so
uh I don't know if any of you can relate
to this you know you might feel it's a
little weird or something but it is a
very fond set of memories for me these
you know canine feline uh companions all
hanging out together uh so every once in
a while you know getting a little bit
irritated with the the others you know
sassy could dislike the dogs like
rolling over too much on her but for the
most part we all really got along and
enjoyed that shmoosh together of
sleeping on the mats and then on the
yogi bows and then later in the big bed